this is why we should never ever like
run into aliens like Humanity we're
[ __ ] we're having Humanity oh yes
[ __ ] you know well then we're thinking
the aliens are any better than us maybe
they're just as bad what do you mean
with like you know thinking and everyone
disagreeing to be honest I don't think
it matters I don't think I think I don't
think it matters what we think yeah
because like uh I think what was it it
was a it was I think it was called the
99 problem that was like posed by some
[ __ ] force or something but it was
this like yeah Socrates
she's the only ever person who's fought
back to you well like I think it was
something along the lines of like
um and please fact check me on this guy
um but like I think it's something along
the lines of like the the DNA like
genetic difference between uh or
disposition between like apes like
monkeys and chimpanzees and us is that
uh I think there is like a 99 match when
it comes to like DNA like basic
structural DNA and that one percent that
chimps don't have is what makes us that
that much smarter right ships I saw I
saw her a [ __ ] thing uh someone
tweeted it was really dumb as [ __ ] they
were like oh well yeah we just have more
DNA so like
and then and then someone applied being
like you know there's more DNA and an
onion than a human yeah yeah it's got
nothing to do with it
stuff like lizard dna in US like when
when why do you think Lizardman exists
sweating right now aside from [ __ ]
Mark Zuckerberg you know the biggest
proof that there is yeah like I believe
like when we're embryos we still like
form a lizard tale that right
no we gotta fact check this uh please
fact check that but like
if you're right I I'll I'll give I'll
give you uh crisp handshake if you're
right do we evolve with lizard Tails
when when we're babies have we grow I
believe we grow a slight tailbone and
then it disappears going back to uh yeah
maybe that's [ __ ] weird if that is
swear to God
yeah oh I'm sure well isn't the Cox it's
just an after uh oh like you know it's
just the leftovers of the tales that we
used to have as you know when we're rape
sorry isn't that what that is
it well isn't that why like the appendix
as well is like just the uh The
Leftovers of the like the second stomach
that supposedly like we used to have bro
the appendix man well don't get me
started on the [ __ ] appendix why do
we have two lungs why not just one just
one big one just one big one why do we
not only have one nostril why do we I
don't have two hearts yes
[Music]
correct yeah yeah I believe that I mean
yeah the human tails thing it says that
a half a billion years is
apparently sprouted Tails almost their
balance yeah yeah so it's just like an
after like do we still evolve but but
what I think God is saying is that when
we reproduce now
okay okay
but like going back to the 99 problem
right it's called the 99 problem because
hypothetically right if an alien species
came to Earth yeah right and they looked
exactly like us right or maybe not even
exactly like this but genetically they
were exactly like us but now it's the
opposite of what we had with the Apes
now we have a 99 disposition between us
the human race and these aliens but the
extra one percent we don't have is what
makes the aliens that much smarter so
much of a difference that is that it's
the equivalent to US between chimps
right so it's like you know we look at a
chimp like playing around with some
blocks and you know the chimp puts the
square block into the square hole and
we're like
very good you know my my son just
learned algebra two weeks ago right that
could be the same thing for the aliens
the aliens would be like oh you're
learning quantum physics or my
five-year-old just learned that the
other day yeah exactly like that's
terrible so like so the real question is
why would aliens right
give a [ __ ] about what we think okay but
like here's here's one thing because to
them we're probably just like The Chimps
yeah that's that's that's an argument
and that's why it's scary yeah that's
why it's [ __ ] terrified that's why I
don't think we should ever like
encounter aliens at all but like one
thing I've kind of just realized during
this one conversation is that we've
we've had we've had one like example of
evolution yeah an example that's
happened on earth right yeah and uh
We've evolved you know intellect
smartness and we've seen that in animals
one thing I'm kind of noticing now is
that
um the smaller you are the more likely
you are to just be an [ __ ] what if
that's just like what if that's what if
you know you know what I mean well
because you realize that you can [ __ ]
people in there yeah also like how as a
lion do you [ __ ] someone over as an
[ __ ] what if that's just I don't know
man like pushing your child off a cliff
that's a pretty big [ __ ] move like
what if what if that's just an earth
thing what if you can just evolve
intellect without being an ass
what if that's just something that's
just outside of our perception that's
what I'm saying man we are still the
Neanderthals in this chain thousands of
years from now we are going to be humans
that will develop something
like you're just describing like plants
they just don't do anything they need to
mind their business we need them we [ __ ]
them up have you not seen that him like
Shyamalan film that's what I'm saying
man we got to start cutting a big
dollars out I'm telling you like this
maybe if we could stop feeling emotions
we wouldn't be nice decided that you
know a dolphin killing a child is an
[ __ ] move maybe to them they're like
what the [ __ ] is your normal Tuesday
we we decide we're putting our morals on
a [ __ ] dolphin like the dolphin gives
a [ __ ] so what you're saying is [ __ ]
are human construct yes what we just
fight is decide as an [ __ ] changes
every [ __ ] generation that's true
that's true right like we had like uh I
don't know like yeah you could smoke
indoors before if you did that I think
you're an [ __ ]
you could do that like 50 years ago so
we've just gotten more sense yeah well
we've just changed like what we think is
acceptable and not yes of course yeah I
mean social norms are always changing
yeah yeah you know it's no different
manual are they evolving evolving that's
all that's up for debates I wouldn't
exactly I don't think it's fair to say
it's cut and dry yeah evolving is not
the term yeah it's like it's VR porn
Evolution or Devolution I don't know but
uh I don't know how it's like helping
the human race
technology it is definitely the
evolution in every other aspect
oh my God is there a Survivor bias with
evolution
I don't know isn't that the whole point
of evolution it is literally
survivorship but
see I don't know it I feel now it's
gotten to the point where that's not the
thing that determines
the next step in evolution like
I like could you like Okay so let's say
like dinosaurs just got [ __ ] over yeah
like they couldn't have evolved their
way out of being struck by a [ __ ]
meteor yeah yeah
right so like in some ways it's like
yeah survival to finish oh with a few
asterisks well the thing is of course
the humans don't turn up yeah I've
decided to destroy your home well that's
like that's like uh interesting actually
because I I think I saw like a let me
know video about like the apocalypse and
I think like the conclusion he came up
to is that it's actually really really
[ __ ] hard to completely wipe oh yeah
Wipe Out the human rights right yes yes
we know this because we're we have like
[ __ ] bunkers and [ __ ] underground
yeah yeah yeah stockpiling the only way
is to literally just blow up the Earth
yeah exactly just wipe out all of that
yeah for every you know let's say there
was a you know a nuclear bomb went off
you know not everyone who gets striked
by that dies yeah yeah exactly Will
Survive it maybe it's not the healthiest
but the people who make it through yeah
no exactly it's it's really really hard
to completely Wipe Out the human race
yes as it is right now we're like
cockroaches but big yeah
we're the [ __ ] virus where the virus
we are the Cockroaches onto the next
level next level of humanity is just
like the Cockroach men and terraformers
perhaps all we're gonna evolve into dude
it's like reverse Planet of the Apes we
were the Cockroaches all along you know
I think she's ahead of point
something to think about what were you
saying before about uh yeah obviously
like and all it took was an asteroid to
like wipe out all of the dinosaurs yes
but they weren't smart enough to like
not survive without that you know they
wanted because they were too [ __ ] big
you're literally a small brain that's
what that's what that's a lot it's like
God what you're saying is if there's
dinosaurs evolved enough to the point
where they're like you know what there
might be this thing that falls from the
sky one day and we just all get wiped
out over it so let's build a bunker
underground to save ourselves I mean
yeah then the dinosaurs could have
survived it's not like an ideal Survivor
you know survivorship yeah but the point
is you can you know there is certain
sects of humanity that through millions
of years can eventually repopulate the
world I'm glad there are crazy bunker
people out there yeah because we need we
need them yeah yeah I don't want to be
one I'm happy to die when the when the
asteroid comes out yeah but aren't you
then afraid that those are the people
who are going to be the next Humanity
bro if you look back a thousand and you
see people we had we didn't have much
better I think we turned out okay I
think I think I think we'll be all right
well we'll pick ourselves back up again
I'm sure
yeah did you see how World War One
started like I think uh yeah sure we
haven't we don't have a good track
record of the smartest people being in
the best position yeah yeah I mean uh
we're doing all right
yeah absolutely hopefully we learn from
our mistakes yeah as a species
I mean that's why historians say we get
10 things wrong 10 things wrong and one
thing right every now and then yeah
what I've learned is that like Evolution
and survival of the Fitters doesn't get
rid of stupid people
that's what I've learned it's because if
you think about it oh no stupid people
have always been around it's just the
idea of what is considered stupid yeah
because it's because like let's say it's
the whole thing with politics rights my
agenda is better than yours and and it's
for them that's Survival and the way
that they want to live and that's there
so that's you know you're getting into
that now so every single person on the
internet who says like oh survival of
the food is we'll get rid of all the
dumb people and be a smarter human race
I don't think that's alpha males yeah
yeah alpha males I don't think that's
ever gonna happen
no I mean because then because then once
you get rid of all those people there's
gonna be a new type or personality or
trait of some kind that will just fill
its place again I mean our strength as
humans is that we have like everything
stupidity is a social construct someone
someone someone thought hey we should
just make something that [ __ ] flies
and can carry me it's like no one ever
that's the dumbest [ __ ] ever heard if I
was like Middle Ages I'm like [ __ ] off
oh yeah yeah don't people make the world
we need we need crazy people to come up
with the coolest [ __ ] yes of course I
mean stuffed insane yeah because that's
the same they've actually made pizza
crusts edible but like yeah the first
person who came up with that they were
like oh whoa whoa whoa why are they tell
he's not figuring this out
let's go completely off topic well like
we need crazy people I I like to think
that stuff crossed was invented when
someone just took a pizza and just
rolled it up it was just like
yeah yeah
hang on on a second I can do that but I
remember I remember I had this
conversation with Joey Watts where it's
just like who do you think like invented
the first [ __ ] you know do you
remember this conversation yeah we
talked about an afternog I'm pretty sure
did we actually I think so I think I had
the same response of like the [ __ ]
sake I'm sure people were doing it they
just didn't put a name to it you know
you know what I mean like thinking like
philosophy we didn't put a name to
philosophy I think we Googled it and it
was like the Greeks or the Romans the
Romans it was popularized again it's a
philosophy thing all over again they
just put a name on it they invented
PornHub okay Romans invented giving head
they were so five-handed that they
decided to give heads
and that's how you know our generation
is [ __ ] if you guys are listening to
us oh damn it
podcast yes genuine like
math that's a weird thing to me off
right
math exists we just figured out how to
explain it as my physics teacher once
said
science makes maths its [ __ ] yeah but
like if without science think about math
would be pointing if you think about it
math is like the universal language it's
the only language there technically
isn't it crazy that the Indians invented
zero okay okay
I'm actually gonna kill you guys okay
okay so
math is just like English but we just
use that to explain the things that are
happening and how they interact it's
just a language that we chose right yeah
it's a it's a human culture
and we it's the way that we communicate
does math exist outside of humans of
course it does yeah but like the concept
of explaining it doesn't but like the
stuff interacting and all the the the
the formulas that are happening those
things are happening whether we know
like do you do you not find it weird
Okay this this is what blows my [ __ ]
mind right you know the you know you
know like a few years ago where they
changed what a kilogram is right they
mathematically change what a kilogram is
because before they had this weight that
was a kilogram it was like in a [ __ ]
bunker in France or some [ __ ] yeah and
that was a kilogram yeah and then they
changed it to be more space scientists
on equations that used a universal
constant I believe it's like a consonant
constant the plan constant
why are there constants in our law of
the universe does that know that that
[ __ ] me okay why is why is this why did
like the universe go yo speed of light
sure that's the thing now that's like
that's as fast as you can go to give you
a very easy way of kind of explaining
this is that like the difference between
Celsius and Fahrenheit they're both
communicating the same thing right
but they both they're entirely different
numbers right but one is dumb but yeah
exactly you can convert right yeah and
it's the same thing if we rebuilt math
again from the ground up we could make
new constants that matched all the
formulas that we'd already made right
yes it's just
we have decided that for our math we're
going to use this is the constant if we
changed it the other constant we chose
would have to change right it's just we
have decided that this is how we're
going to express these these numbers and
these interactions
some Indian one day was just like
we need a number that means nothing and
before that there was no number four
it's crazy
so think about it right because I'd say
numbers back then was purely for like
like trade or whatever you're using it
right so you would you would have one of
something you never had zero of
something so there's no need to have a
zero because your meth wasn't using that
concept yeah but surely before okay
caveman all right you need to
communicate hey there are three X's
along there are three deers that we can
hunt surely surely that was a concept
that was needed before markets and
selling stuff existed surely yeah but
the Nintendo Falls once standing around
being like there are Zero D is to hunt
goodbye goodbye